you
okay hi my name is amber Nicotra Minh
and I am happy to welcome Amit Sharma a
postdoc researcher from MSR New York to
talk today I meet got his PhD from
Cornell University where he's working
with ban costly on looking at what types
of factors affect and shape people's
online behaviors
since he's joined MSR New York City he's
been looking at some causal inference
applying causal inference to those same
studies to learn more about how people
behave online today he's going to talk
to us about data mining for causal
inference thanks sir thanks a lot I'm
Bray yeah as you mentioned when I in the
past two years I've been a postdoc I've
really started thinking more deeply
about causal inference and this talk is
a little bit different from the
traditional causal inference of what I'm
going to argue is that as we have these
scenarios where in almost all kinds of
fields we have large amounts of
observational data we may need to use
some new approaches to make sense of
them right and data mining could be one
way that we can use techniques from
computer science to help causal
inference but before all of that I'm
going to tell a story and this is a very
historical story it starts in 1854 when
London was having a devastating cholera
outbreak and here's a map of London
we're in the middle paths here there is
a huge amount of cholera incidences and
then there are people getting affected
all across London so the burning
question then was what is causing
cholera right so there was the
privileged hypothesis which is that it's
an airborne disease it just spreads
through air another hypothesis was that
it's through water and the last one was
that it's just the neighbourhoods it's
just the people who live in certain
neighborhoods that get cholera so in
terms of causal graphical models you can
think of polluted air is colouring
cholera diagnosis or you could think
that contaminated water is colouring
calder diagnosis and in both of these
note that these variables are denoted by
nodes and then each arrow determines a
causal connection right so this is
saying exactly that contaminated water
is causing
cauldre diagnosis but things are not so
simple it could also be something very
confounding where the neighborhood
actually determines both whether you get
contaminated water and also whether you
get cholera right so it's not as easy as
to just look at the people who are
living in certain neighborhoods and
directly tell what's going on so John
Snow was a physician at the time and he
really believed that it was contaminated
water and he had a lot of evidence for
it but people would not believe him so
finally he found the source of the
cholera outbreak and he found this bump
on Broad Street which is now famous now
it's almost tourist attraction and he
says that most of the people who were
getting ill were getting water from that
pump right now you would believe that
once you have that evidence people would
start not having consuming water from
there but even this was not convincing
and you can think of why right so it
could just be that it's not the pump
it's just the people who are living
around the pump that are more likely to
get this disease maybe just because of
the polluted air in that area right and
it could be other reasons as well it
could just be the socioeconomic status
of people living around and the kinds of
activities that they do that leads to
cholera it's that nothing to do with a
pump and so finally after many months he
had a stroke of genius and he was able
to solve this issue and what happened
was that he finally figured out that
there are two water companies to London
and one of them has its supply
downstream from London which means it's
contaminated by sewage and the other has
upstream so here Lambert's company is
upstream water is pure South Park and
Vauxhall was downstream water is impure
that's the only difference between those
two companies and he showed that there's
an Eightfold difference between cholera
deaths for people who have water from
the Southall Company versus the Lambeth
company right once he had shown that
that these two companies were just
serving water to different people and
the only difference that was causing was
that people were dying more of Cholera
for the company with the contaminated
water people finally agreed so then
there was a warning issued and then
everyone now knows that colorized
through water you should not have
contaminated water but for us the real
question is why was snows last study so
convincing right so there are two main
reasons why Lass's one it is almost
obvious that you can show that the
choice of water company cannot cause
cholera right so remember the in the
pump example people are still not sure
because it could be the other scenario
is there and second he also showed quite
convincingly that the difference could
not be because of air or neighborhood
right so he had this map where he showed
that people were basically interspersed
between these two companies in the same
neighborhood right so if you put two
people in this neighborhood one of them
had different company from the other the
only difference was the company there
was no other neighborhood or air quality
effect more generally it is probably the
first application of cause-effect
principles like there were many
philosophers before aristotle humanik
cetera who were thinking about cause and
effect and had very very good theories
but this was probably the first
application where there were two main
conditions that emerged or causal
inference the first is exclusion which
means that whatever treatment you are
doing such as the water company here
should not affect the outcome should not
affect Colorado and the second is as if
random which is saying that just by
choosing a water company should not tell
us anything about your neighborhood or
other kinds of confounding factors right
and once you have that this is basically
the two key assumptions you need for
causal inference as a front of in a
graphical model essentially means that
the neighborhood should not be causing
the water company that you choose
hopefully that's true and in this case
the water company not causing colorized
kind of obvious but what I'm going to
argue is that it's not just about that
experiment or that example these two
principles if you think about it are
just the basic two needs of causal
elements and in the 1930s Fisher's
showed the randomized experiment where
again all you need for this randomized
experiment to be valid is again just
exclusion and as if random so exclusion
means the randomized should not affect
outcome and as at random just means that
randomized assignment by definition
is random so it's not caused by anything
else and so with the observational data
such analysis is called a natural
experiment the only difference is that Z
is now an observed variable it's called
an instrumental variable the problem
though is that ensuring these
restrictions becomes insanely hard one
because as if random in exclusion depend
on unobserved confounders and two
because it's just really hard to find
instruments like these like Jon Snow
found even for him a genius it took
months to find something else convincing
and so really this is the current state
of affairs in natural experiments
they're widely used they're really
important so the right answer can't be
that let let's just do experiments
everywhere they are used across in
social sciences in Health Sciences and
also more recently in understanding the
effect of algorithmic systems so think
of recommendation systems search systems
how do they affect people's behavior all
of these questions are such where you
cannot do experiments all the time so
it's important to do natural experiments
but there are three problems first
finding any kind of valid instrument
requires creative ingenuity second even
if you can do that it still allows you
to only see some single source sharks or
like the weather or lottery it is hard
to actually think of many experiments
just because of the scale or finding
them and the third is that even if you
do that it's hard to give guarantees on
whether the exclusion or as a fandom is
satisfied so it's really a matter of
finding these experiments just to find
them and then hoping that it would be
convincing enough for people to take it
up and so the key question we came up
with was that this is great but we are
now in a scenario where potentially we
have a lot of data and also a lot of
data with a lot of covariance right so
if we were to design natural experiments
today is there anything better that we
can do given that we have computational
power and more kinds of observational
data available and that's the key focus
of this talk how do we discover natural
experiments as more and more
fine-grained data is available and this
essentially requires inverter
how we think about natural experiments
so historically as John snow also was
doing we would hypothesize about a
natural variation so think of the two
companies we would somehow find out that
that's important and then we would argue
why it looks just like a randomized
experiment because people were not
choosing companies based on their
cholera incidents and once you have that
you compute the causal effect here's an
alternative approach to do it which is
the focus of this talk let's develop
tests for natural variation that we
believe are as if random and follow
exclusion and this is sort of the meat
of the analysis and I'll talk more in
detail about how you do that but the
nice thing is that once you have such
tests then what you can do is you can
just mine your observational data for
these kinds of variations once you get
the ones that well that are valid you
just compute the causal effect right and
the way you do this is by using a lot of
the theory that you do Paul and others
have developed for causal graphical
models so I've already showed you this
graphical model before more
theoretically this is actually a Markov
network where you all you're assuming is
that all of these arrows are causes and
the removal of exclusion and as a front
of arrows makes something a valid
natural experiment and what I'm going to
show is that it can help us molecule
behavior in online systems that's
primarily what I've studied but the
insights that we get from these studies
would also potentially have causal
influence in other fields all right so
here are the two main key results that
I'm going to show today the first is a
data driven method that extends
instrumental variables and the second is
a more general criterion which we call
the split or criterion that it can be
applied almost anywhere where you have
time series data and some auxilary
outcome to use so for this stock the
main motivating example I'm going to use
is recommendation systems for two
reasons one because in my PhD I was
working on recommendation systems so
this was just an natural thing I was
interested in and gravitated towards
when I studied causal inference and
second is that we have systems which
gave us very very fine-grained data to
do these
data mining exercises and it's sort of
the harbinger of what we can do in other
scenarios when such kinds of data would
become available in those domains as
well so the question is simple suppose
your Amazon or suppose you have a App
Store like Microsoft what do we do to
understand the effect of recommendations
in other words we spend a lot of money
and effort on building these
recommendation systems what is the
effect of showing people recommendations
does it increase people's view time it
doesn't increase revenue so on so look
at the literature there's a lot of
marketing literature that shows that
they have a huge effect so for example
emarketer had a survey which showed that
about 30% of traffic comes from
recommendations that's a big number so
it's almost saying like how one-third of
all traffic that comes on a website is
your recommendation and there's a code
which say is that one of the sports
retailer Reports 25% of total sales as
well from recommendations but if you
quickly think about it that must be an
overestimate right because we are not
really interested in just the
observational estimate of how many
clicks come through recommendation what
we really should be concerned about is
this question what would happen if there
was no recommendation and this is a
scenario here right so it so it's fine
that there are some clicks happening to
recommendations but the real question we
want to answer causally is if there were
no recommendations that allows the
behavior and you can almost think of it
in terms of the counterfactual that the
observed estimate has to be an
overestimate right imagine whatever you
see in the observed data as this block
and whatever you would not see the of
the observed with it without the
recommender as the other block the
reason I'm claiming this is because if
you look at this recommendations these
two could have just happened just
because the user was interested in
winter accessories right so right now
it's November suppose it's December and
everyone is buying caps it's almost very
likely that that person without
recommendations would also search for
gloves and this essentially becomes this
red box here which is convenience clicks
and really you want to know the kind of
clicks that would not have happened
without the recommender more generally
it's the problem of career demand
recommendation systems are designed to
show you people who bought this also
bought so in some sense they are
inherently capturing this correlated
demand even if you don't show
recommendations for example in this case
a user could go from demand for winter
accessories to buying a hat and then
buying gloves or they might just not see
the recommendations and go directly from
their demand for winter accessories to
buying gloves as well so that's the key
question we hope we can solve it by
finding some magical Z and I'm going to
show you how you can do that in a way
that sort of extends to all of Amazon
but again the key problem here as you
can imagine is is that we have to find a
magical Z such that it's not affected by
the demand and it also does not affect
the recommendation traffic an obvious
answer would be what wieder just do an
experiment you could show
recommendations to half of the customers
you could show no recommendations to the
other half this is valid but in this
case it might be a really costly
experiment because what we are doing is
we're sort of removing a part of the UI
that is very very useful for many users
and also they may also have a
requirement that you need full access to
the system so suppose B want to study
Amazon and we do and we are in Microsoft
it is hard to do that if you don't have
access to the system and more generally
the goal of this exercise will also to
show how natural experiments can be
useful so we're really looking for an
approach that does not have full access
to the system what do people do in
instead they would find a natural source
of variation so in Oprah is a very good
natural source of variation so what
people have done is just use Oprah for
finding natural experiments how would
this work so as I said the main first
key point is that you want a hypothesis
hypothesize about a natural variation in
this case Oprah has books in her book
club and it turns out that whenever she
recommends a book a lot of people go on
Amazon or any other website to search
for it right so the way the traditional
approach would work is that from
theoretical basis you know that Oprah
causes
huge shock to books on Amazon so you
would say Jenny McCarthy went on Oprah's
Book Club her book is louder than words
when you look at Amazon's traffic it's
going to have a huge spike in its demand
the day she went on the show now what
you can do is you can also look at the
recommended products on Amazon for that
book and you can just say that whatever
is the spike that you observe for these
recommended products should be the
effect of the recommender the only
caveat is that we have to be just a
little bit careful because we want to
ensure that the exclusion is satisfied
right so for example imagine that this
was Jenny McCarthy's book and this is
also Jenny McCarthy's book you can
always certainly think of that if people
were going on Jenny McCarthy's main book
because of the show they will also have
a higher likelihood of clicking on Jenny
McCarthy's other book because of the
show right this is exactly karuta to
demand and this is what we want to
somehow control for if you want to get
causal estimates and so what you can do
is that you can just say that Oh same
authors is not a good idea because I can
see that the demand for both would also
be rising so let's not condition for
same authors but you can clearly think
that there can be many other cases where
this would be invalidated right so it
could be same authors it could be the
same series think of Harry Potter one
versus Harry Potter 2 and so on so you
need complicated statistical models to
actually control for collated demand and
people have done this in the past two
main worries the assumptions are hard to
verify and finding examples of valid
sharks really requires a lot of
ingenuity the method I'm going to
propose uses also lower data but it then
allows us to have a simple data driven
method for identifying sharks how does
it work well the first-order condition
or the 0th condition as I say here is
that you need to get some kind of new
data that you did not have before in
this case we are lucky because we have a
well-functioning system that logs each
wizard
so for each was at that a user does we
know exactly whether it was because I've
directed with it or recommender visits
so think of direct visits as anything
happens without the recommender and we
can use this as a proxy for the
unobserved demand that we are not able
to see right the interesting part is
that just by having this auxiliary
outcome which is by the way commonly
recorded in almost all online systems we
can just invert the way natural
experiments are found so now we don't
think about opera we don't think about
any external shock all we have is the
Amazon data set and we say that let's
look for the products that have a huge
shock in their traffic so I don't know
anything about the product all I go is
all I do is go into the logs search for
the time series where one product has a
huge shock in traffic turns out I find
this book once we have that we can look
for any recommended product to this book
and just have a condition that the
direct visits for that product was not
also spiking right so this is the test
for exclusion if exclusion is really
satisfied then a huge increase in demand
for this product should have no effect
on the demand for that product and in
this case we find the other book that we
were getting in Oprah example right and
now you only think about it all that we
are saying is that here is a book that
got a huge shock in traffic for some
reason we also see that the recommended
book did not have a huge shock in its
demand because direct visits captured
that then whatever increase we found in
the recommendation traffic which is the
spike here has to be because of the
recommender in other words if the demand
is not increasing then the any increase
in recommendations that you find has to
be because of this new recommendations
that you showed and similarly we can use
the same technique to negate out invalid
shocks so for example if you have a book
like this where both our books have the
same author we would find that this book
gets a shock in demand direct visits for
the recommended book also gets a shock
and so we don't want that we would not
take them as valid estimates we would
just throw out this sample so really all
you're doing is you're looking at the
entire dataset and trying to find
subsets where a national experiment is
valid and the nice thing is that
compared to past work where you have to
look at a lot of controls and
very complicated statistical methods to
to estimate the causal effect if you can
design the experiment in a way that you
are conditioning for exclusion and as if
random conditions then the estimation is
really simple so it's literally just a
division integer float division so here
you have the increase in visits because
of the focal product and then you have
the increase in recommendation visits to
the recommended product all we have to
do now is to just do the Delta in the
recommendation traffic and divided by
the Delta in the total visits right and
because we are assuming that the first
product was having a shock the second
product wasn't this Delta could not have
happened without the recommender as
simple as that
any questions regarding the intuition
before I explain more how it works all
right so it just seems too easy to be
true because all I'm saying is that
search for products that receive a
sudden shock in their traffic and just
restrict to direct traffic for the
recommendations to remain constant it
works because just like the early
examples I showed this sudden shock is
nothing but an instrumental variable so
more specifically what we are seeing
here is that the focal visits aren't
having a shock in their traffic the
recommendation visits are also having a
sharp in their traffic in this case we
can't say much but whenever we have
direct visits which is a proxy for
demand that does not have have a shock
in traffic then we can be sure that the
exclusion restriction is satisfied
another way of seeing is that is that in
general we want to have focal product
and recommended products we know that
some of them are good and they meet the
criteria for national experiments we
know that some of them fail in general
it's hard to know which one is which but
if we have some auxiliary data like the
direct visits for the recommended
product then we can just sort of look
for the time series and based on the
time series just select which one to
pick so because we were Microsoft we had
this nice Bing tool bar data which is
anonymize data of people using the Bing
toolbar which they provide to
so we had non amazed browsing logs for
25 million pageviews on Amazon products
and so what I'm going to show you is
actually apply this method on a subset
of Amazon users and and show what we get
about the impact of a recommendation
system so this was about nine months of
data and we had about as I said 1.3
million products the first thing is to
just look at the trends just to make
sure that the data we have is reflecting
what we believe about Amazon so for
example you can see the number of
products and page views really spikes
during December kind of makes sense the
holiday season we also find that books
and ebooks are still by far the most
popular at least for this population
that we studied there are also other
kinds of categories that come up which
are also browsed by people the one thing
that was a slight problem was that how
do we now go from this data set which is
just logs of people's visits to what we
really want which is a focal product a
recommended product and their time
series because we don't know anything
about recommendations all we get are the
logs we got lucky because Amazon
actually shows their recommendation
links in their URL itself so if you were
to go on a sales page then go a focal
product page and then go out a
recommended product page then you can
clearly see the links that tell you
exactly what was happening so for
example here you would get a referral
link which tells you that the user was
searching for George Saunders the second
link where sr1 one means that you
clicked on the first result first link
and then you also get other kinds of
URLs which tells you which
recommendation the user clicked on so
once we have that we essentially can
connect instruct how a user was going
through in their session and reconstruct
the focal visits and recommended visits
once we have that the application is
pretty straightforward I told you we
need shocks and we need to ensure that
the shocks are not transferring to
direct traffic of the recommendation so
we just try a bunch of different
techniques we say that the shock should
be five times the median traffic for any
we also say it should be five times the
previous day's traffic and five times
the mean of seven days you can also
think of other strategies and we show
that in the paper the the real point is
that we want some reasonable strategy to
identify sharks and then we also want
these shark products to be actually
representative of actual products so we
don't want BOTS or other things to
impact analysis so I felt of a bots and
we also require that you have at least
ten unique users for each product using
no uncovering things that look like
after the fact we can check this is what
we have done did you pick up most of the
overall now let's just say yeah yeah we
did not pick up Opera I think was
because of the sample we had we picked
up a lot of Today Show and dr. Oz Show
for some reason but yeah so that's the
interesting part so once you discover
them you can go back and check which
ones are the ones you would trust more
the second thing was insuring constant
direct traffic that's pretty simple you
just have a condition for this kind of
time series to look relatively constant
so we would accept something like this
but we would reject something like that
because we are not sure of what's going
on it's like both products are having a
huge spike in their demand the first
result is that just by doing this and
remember we were not being clever at all
all we did was that we had some data we
applied some conditions we obtained
4,000 potential natural experiments this
is quite an interesting result because
in general it's hard to get even a few
natural experiments so in other words
it's about 20% of all products that had
10 with it yeah see the absence of the
shot or direct and recommend traffic's
correlated week to week yes we can't do
that and that's I'm imagining sort of a
worst case scenario for you which is
something like you're thinking you're
choosing between including and excluding
shocks based on the direct traffic right
maybe there should have been a shot but
you chose not to include it because that
happened to be a bad week for the
products right I'm both correct
yes there's a little bit of a sample
selection problem
yes there is so the Advocate random
assumption is not completely satisfying
I'll come to that and talk about how we
can do once we have that we can also
compute the causal estimate that we were
really after so we have these now
natural experiments that spread across
all different products which is another
nice thing that sort of comes
automatically out of the box it's hard
to find Oprah
level shocks for sports or apparel but
we are just looking for time serious
shocks then it's possible to get them
and the key result if you want to see
this figure is that if we were just
looking at the number of clicks we would
get an average about nine point six
percent causal rate so essentially if
you show recommendations about 10% of
them convert to a click but if you then
not only restrict the shocks which we
believe are more closer to the causal
estimate then almost always is less than
5% in other words roughly a quarter of
all the click throughs are causal the
rest 75% may be due to convenience or
they may be just due to people browsing
out of seeing recommendations not
anything about the causal effect and you
can also see it sort of varies a little
bit based on categories but most of the
times it's well below 5% now Matt
pointed out a good question is that we
are now having some benefit that we have
a lot of these sharks and we can analyze
causal effects but then we have the
strange condition where we're just
looking for this strong spike in one and
constant another so there might be a lot
of concerns for the odds of random
assumption right the exclusion is fine
but what about maybe all these sharks
that you dose discounts or sales or they
might just be because of the holiday
season where you're finding empirically
that people tend to click less on
recommendations so another thing that I
would suggest if you are taking such an
approach is to do a lot of robustness
checks and we did that with using other
kinds of data where we hovered disclude
products will have sharks we would
dispute products we have discounts or
sales and we found that the effects
don't worry by much so this is one way
of confirming
that you're not capturing something
egregious another way of doing that is
to just realize that it is true that we
are capturing something very very
specific but the better way is now that
we are capturing it for a lot of
products right so it may not be true
that it's valid for all products
probably there are some products that
are not at all shocked and so this would
not apply to them but at least for those
products during the times that they were
shocked this is a valid causal estimate
and interestingly we also found that
these estimates are consistent with
prior experimental results on websites
so in summary let me tell you the two
good points about this approach and then
I'm going to talk a little more about
what I'm still not satisfied with so the
good points is one we get a lot of
shocks
compared to past methods and the second
is we can test for exclusion directly
but the problem is with a safe random
shocks are capturing a very rare
specialized event and they might be
actually getting us to a subset of the
data that may not be representative for
whatever reason so one way to think of
it is that let's try to even generalize
this criterion a little bit more and so
what we now going to do is that we are
going to go less strict on the exclusion
restriction right so we are going to be
more admissible for the kinds of shocks
that we are going to get but then we
would also get a lot of generalizability
in return you can almost think of it as
the bias-variance tradeoff the way this
works is by just looking thinking a
little bit more about what we were
really after when you are looking at
sharks right so if I just recollect the
figure again we wanted a huge shock to
focal products and we wanted an almost
constant direct traffic but really all
we were saying was that this sudden
shock affects the focal visits and does
not affect the recommendation product
right and because we did not have better
ways of doing it we were just saying oh
this has to have a big shock that has to
be a constant but why all we require is
that direct traffic should not be
affected by focal product by the visits
to the focal product which means no
correlated demand
what about this so let's take some
examples and try to test our intuition
on what is that that we're really after
when we are doing these natural
experiments suppose there is a product
which has a huge shock and suppose it
has a recommended product whose direct
with its always keeps increasing this is
like the best product you can make like
people just keep wanting more and more
of it all the time if you now see that
recommendation traffic still has a bump
when the focal visits had a bump what
would we say right if you believe that
that direct visits is a good proxy for
demand then we can argue that this bump
would not have happened without the
corresponding bump from this local
visits right so maybe we should accept
this as well what about this case right
so this is just I made it I don't think
any product has sinusoidal waves but
it's just sort of captured the intuition
of what we're really after if you really
believe that requisites are
independently sinusoidally wearing and
we observe a shock to the focal product
and the observed recommendation traffic
it's again an arguable case to make that
that bump would not have happened if
there was no recommendation traffic
between these two products right so what
I'm going after all I'm saying is that
instead of searching for shocks we can
just make it a much more general
strategy where all we are saying is that
the focal visits and the direct visits
should be independent and so it's sort
of a simple statistical criterion which
says X should be independent of yd and
to the extent that we can discover this
from observational data we should be
good again you might think why this
works this actually has much better
theoretical guarantees than the method I
proposed before
essentially you can show that if you
have data that comes from this graphical
model where the only assumption we are
making is that the recommendation visits
and direct visits come from the same
demand which means that the recommended
product has some underlying demand and
it sort of informs both the
recommendations and the clicks then you
can show using pols graphical calculus
that statistical independence of x and y
D would essentially guarantee that this
path between for
let's interact with it but goes from
demand uh I cannot exist and then the
only restriction that you have is either
this arrow does not exist or the demand
is constant in both cases you would have
a scenario where the visits traffic is
confounded once we have that we can just
quickly check how it works so let's do
that
the only condition now we have to check
is whether x and y d are independent
this is generally a hard problem in
statistics because if you do not have a
lot of data and you cannot use methods
like mutual information then it's just
hard to know just observational e
whether two things are independent right
so we're going to take a sort of an
assumption here that if we can find in
the observed data that there is a very
little probability for dependence then
you're going to assume that these two
time series are independent and the
precise way we do it is by using
officials test so we divide the data
into fifteen days and for each of these
subsets of fifteen day periods we going
to find product pairs x and y such that
their conditional probabilities are
independent and again once we have that
the actual estimation is pretty easy
it's again just a float division what
you find is that the causal CTR is again
very similar to what we found from the
shock ivy that's reassuring so it's even
though these are completely different
methods one of them was using sharks one
of them is using a completely different
sample it's reassuring that we are
almost there with the same estimates
what's encouraging is the just the scale
that split door now allows us to get so
remember shock ivy was giving us about
four thousand sharks split door now
allows us to make it to about twelve
thousand yeah humans
800 sharks oh that's an interesting
question so we that was on a different
day exactly you will hopefully think you
know the same ones
yes repel from yes so that was on a
different data set so we couldn't
directly compare because that was an
earlier time when they were looking at
for two or three years
of all New York Times and Oprah
Winfrey's recommendations but what we
have seen is that actually the shock ivy
would be more likely a superset of the
kind of shocks that you find from these
known external events because they
usually have this characteristic of a
huge spike on one day the split door
criterion I think it's harder because
some of the shocks that are you come up
are not like what you would think of as
an external event it's just that because
of the statistical properties they would
look like independent but I think it's
an open question of how you would use so
that so I'm losing one approach where
you don't look at external events and
you just go through this analysis you
get something that you can put on a
dashboard and check a reasonable causal
estimate the other approaches you can
invert the analysis and say I got twelve
thousand natural experiments now let me
find the ones I trust right so you could
go back and check essentially or you're
making the claim that the only
uncompounded things or related to me and
right then you have a process for that
yeah it's so you know having some idea
about where the variations coming from
may help people trust that the only
uncompetitive thing is this poorly
planned and accurately capture so
perhaps the car me at all paper has a
methodology that could be easily
extended to like your time period you
know the you know maybe with some simple
searching you could reconstruct what
their IV checkbox would be in every time
period and then you know if you you know
hopefully then you know you could yeah
look for the differences and then you
can actually investigate the differences
and say oh you know what
they thought these eight hundred work
great but I only picked up six hundred
and then looking at the remaining 200
Wow they really didn't you know see what
was going on here but we were able to
drill down yeah so you get you can start
to a piece of part of the benefits and
strengths from the two erections that's
a cool idea yeah I think we can explore
that yeah I don't know if you have data
available because but it I like the side
because then it'll also allow us to see
and compare previous methods to how this
is working you know maybe there's as
since they're using I'm assuming some
popularity measure they're only looking
at high-traffic items right yours maybe
is more across the distribution it's
better also tell us about how
generalizability the two are they both
may be true for their own stuff like
that's that's it yeah I just real quick
looking at these four thousand and
twelve thousand shocks what's the
denominator they're like how many things
were classified as shocks and then not
use oh I see so the denominator is
essentially twenty two thousand I
believe which is all the products that
had at least ten visits on any given day
nobody you must have picked a certain
number of shocks and then oh I think so
I don't have those plots here but
essentially if I remember correctly I
think you get about for example per
shock I mean you would get about thirty
to forty thousand sharks and then and
then this is different split criterion
this is the actual thinking of the shock
different or is it just the independence
criteria so the independence recognized
different it could saying sometimes it's
more general because it also have some
shocks
okay and also have some other things
that are completely different just
reminding you real quick the estimate of
three point two from this criterion how
did that compare the shock ivy with a
it's so sharp IV was seen percent what a
shock wave has averaged three percent
this paper says they don't be basically
identical yes okay and then one other
nice thing is that for split door you
also get a very nice understandable
parameter which is just a p-value for
the independence test so depending on
how you worry that you can get different
robustness checks so the way we are
doing
negating that is by just having stricter
and stricter independence criterion but
it's a problem that we haven't fully
fixed yet so I think what we are showing
you is that we also believe that there's
another problem which is that time
series data is also inherently dependent
right so
so the actual p-value that you get let's
say 5% is not actually 5% because of
this inherent dependence so what we are
showing is that you can use this method
at different values of the significance
level and to the extent that you do not
get a huge change as you chew a this
p-value you should feel more confident
but I think there's a larger question of
when we are doing so many checks across
the data set what does that mean yeah I
agree we haven't solved that problem yet
but there are some ways we are
approaching it so one way would be you
just show that these results became more
and more consistent as you get more data
but it still gives your work yeah and
talking of future work they can be more
one thing that Matt pointed out and even
though the split door criteria does get
to it a little bit by allowing more
natural variations we're still not
getting to the heart of the problem
which is if you have an instrumental
variable right the first one the first
two approaches I showed you were just
for finding them and validating them but
suppose if you had an instrumental
variable and you believe that this is
true to what extent can we test it from
observational data and so this is work
that I'm doing right now and what I'm
finding is that of course it's not
possible to do it for all kinds of
instruments for at all times but if you
have weak instruments and if you have
some discrete discretization of all
variables and we can use something
similar to Bayes factor or Bayesian
model comparison to find the likelihood
of a valid model versus an invalid model
and I find a lot of promise in this line
of work because I think in a lot of
cases we do have good hypotheses about
instruments that we may have passed work
that has it and to the extent that we
can give some guarantees using data the
better we're also more generally I think
these kind of methods will become
important as we get more kinds of
fine-grained data and to questions that
I'm especially interested in as impact
on outcomes like recommendations or
search but also in terms of fairness to
different kinds of users and finally it
was interesting to for me to find out
that these kinds of methods are also
used a cross in epigenetics and they
call it Mendelian randomization but it's
essentially instrumental variables so
I'm trying to think about and
collaborate with computational
biologists to see if these methods may
also be useful and if I have to say just
one slide for this talk it's essentially
that in general it's a hard problem to
find natural experiments for the
different reasons I have described but
if we have fine-grained data and we are
getting increasingly more and more of it
we can be a little bit more useful off
to observe data we have I've shown just
two approaches but I really think this
is just start there can be lots of
better approaches and also a lot of
theory work in understanding what we can
do with these kinds of experiments and
that's it
thanks a lot more questions
yeah so I'm kinda curious so how how
hard do you think it will be to apply
this to to innocence I mean I I think
the the technique for the graphical
model sense looks very general and you
know easy to conceptualize but then the
the what you did you know taking the
browser logs identifying that refer time
was embedded in the URL right and that
this captured the kind of you know
information units is to categorize
direct visits new directive how yeah
yeah it's a good things gonna make this
practical like what should people
building our announcer might be doing or
what right so I think is what's
important is to build these are levels
of graphical models which have good
properties right so I I've sort of
accidentally found one because I was
interested in recommendation systems and
I found that this is actually more
general right but once we have these
different subclasses of graphical models
with good properties you can imagine
just having a software which just asks
you if you have three variables and
suppose there are time series and you
believe they come from this kind of a
graphical model you give me those value
of variables and there'll be a system
that computes causal effects but I think
it's the burden of finding more these
kinds of graphical models is on us
researchers and then the burden of
massaging data so that they fit these
graphical models would I guess would be
more in the practitioners and I think
that's where the hard part is because
unlike machine learning in causal
inference there are no test sets to
validate how good you are doing right so
if you make the assumption like I do
that my recommendations data comes from
this graphical model and I run through
the data and compute an estimate it
really depends on whether I made the
right assumption in modeling it and
currently we don't have good ways to
test it
yes yeah I've been trying I've been
talks about the a/b testing platform so
we're thinking of so that would be even
more impressive I think they're also
think of a very simple approach where
you can sort of start excusing which
experiments to run based on some kind of
natural experiment strategy because
every day they have a lot of experiments
to run yeah but yeah I think that also
would be interesting to do yeah kind of
more abstract question imagine you have
an article yeah that will tell you oh
here's ten hypotheses about calls whole
yeah things that are happening in your
nation as opposed to not having an
article and you just have to look at all
the data to try to find right is there
an advantage to having something that
tells you here's 10 things that are
likely causal and then you can do more
processing to verify whether that's true
or is that really not the hard part you
know it's easy to generate intestine
possible depending on the disease the
hard part is testing and as you just
said if you don't know ground truth the
hard part is not coming up with the
puzzle hypothesis in the first place
it's actually verifying whether it is oh
well it depends on what data scale you
are at so I agree that if you have the
assets of tens of variables then you can
just maybe compute all possible causal
hypothesis and test them which is again
hard but you if you had a way of testing
them you could do it but I think more
and more we are having scenarios where
you would have a data set up think of
people's purchases on a department store
right you would have maybe hundreds
sometimes thousands of variables on what
you have about each person and their
activity and then you would have that
they purchased this level of products
now just to find out what are the key
variables that I should include in my
analysis and which ones I don't is a
computer ill essentially become a
component totaled coming at a really
hard problem very quickly so another way
of thinking about this is that you you
if you have a lot of hypotheses to test
and let's suppose you can do randomized
experiments the testing is easy even
then each experiment requires
Lepore time each experiment requires
some compliance issues and each
experiment would have some gaps some
effect that may or be big or small right
so to the extent that you can just
prioritize them not even not run some of
them but at least you can prioritize
which ones to run first you can have a
lot of benefit in discovering new
knowledge like another example sorry
another example would be the genetic
data sets where this gets even harder
because you have thousands of variables
but which you do not even have intuition
and you're just trying to figure out
which combination of genes would lead to
some combination of diseases so there
it's even harder because we don't even
have intuition to generate hypotheses
yep in the spirit of hypotheticals
alright
so imagine you had a similar scenario
and what you have been what you have
maybe forty thousand potential shots
okay you have no way of detecting which
ones are valid or not valid right but
you know that there's a big massive
balance okay and there are others that
are confounded yeah and maybe what you
believe you believe there's a discrete
mass of valid experiments and then
there's a distribution of confounded
ones that will give you crazy answers
yeah can you
is there anything out there that will
help you hunt without any prior
information for a big cluster of
experiment they kind of all give you the
same answer and then you can sort of
room about any other information with
the crazy ones does any that's well
that's interesting yeah having thought
of this before but you essentially think
you like some clustering approach right
so you have lots of invalid
experimenters there's a big massive
valid ones right about the garbage ones
and I think for a lot of things to say
yes yes yes I think it'll work
especially well in homogeneous datasets
it may not work so well in these kinds
of settings because suppose you have a
lot of products for which different
kinds of effects happen so I didn't show
you but for example apparel usually has
a lot of higher recommendation rate
irrespective of products compared to
books or ebooks right so okay so what
what's happening is that if you have
modernist data set then I think we can
do something like clustering you just
compute the causal effects for each
product cluster them and then hopefully
the biggest one would be the one you
trust yeah but if there are lots of
heterogeneity within the products
themselves so with the notion you might
you know structure your cause of vowels
lots of heterogeneity in the products
you can make expect homogeneity like so
for example I do a lot of work
estimating demand and I think that
elasticity's are mostly come on to this
across okay thanks yeah and so I
estimate my model in terms of penalizing
everything or yeah I mean it's
elasticity's is there a way to structure
the model where the there's a structural
coefficient that you're estimating that
you think is mostly positive I think
yeah that that can happen yeah so we can
do essentially just condition on them
right so so I showed someone upon
observe confounders but some of them are
observed like your last with it or your
product categories I'm sorry structural
coefficient that you're estimating the
percentage of people who see this thing
then go on to buy the other thing right
right and don't you think of that not
every single experiment every single
shock identifies that number right that
is that number is not the same it's it
depends on a lot of different factors
right so oh is the additional on each
product condition on each product
category you might just get different
numbers I mean for example the discovery
of the body is here in some categories I
see refer to a book by name but it'll be
easier an ad if estimated coefficients
if you had let me see if I can go back
so I just looked at one kept eternity
here I see but you're so you're then
saying within a product yes okay which
is a cleaver I don't even know if that's
true but for example look at it here
right yeah so even in the observed
estimates there's a big variation and
then it's it's unclear even within
products imagine cheaper products may be
more people may click more because they
it's a little bias come on the
endogenous for us would give you
estimate of my fifty percent nine to
thirty percent or something
yeah right and you would okay right but
still getting back to a good treatment
effects
yeah but I like what you're suggesting I
just have a little bit of fear that
it'll get into this the same thing as
regression falls into a problem or that
you're controlling for things you know
about but you may not be able to control
for other things but I think to the
extent that after controlling for enough
variation like so let's say we only take
product category and price and we just
bin products in two different categories
compute the estimate
maybe you still be relying on having a
lot of shot then all bins
yes you don't want it doesn't make any
sense yeah okay and if there's another
bin that we would want to have have him
you don't then but I do think is
interesting because in some sense if you
if you don't believe this then that
would also not be believable but if
you're willing to believe this then that
thing can only improve the validity of
what you buy is that if you didn't have
this information that you had about
knowing the structure of the way before
all right like I'm imagining trying to
feed it to like a computer yes and give
me a puzzle answer yeah computer can't
figure anything about it but for crack
whatever
what's an approach that you could try to
con instead yeah yeah but yet your your
approach is obviously better you know
like what that nothing is
yeah
so I see more of a recommendation as
there is some causal effect because of
recommendations now what I want to
compare is if I give you a random for
recommendation versus recommendation
which is language impaired output is
like ministers will have an
accommodation vasilica recommendation
yeah is there something I can deduce
from this data and I say across the
polls here is what was across different
popes upon this Pope is a better
recommendation was yes so we wanted to
do that our data unfortunately was not
that fine-grain so all we could so what
would happen is that whatever was the
first clicked first shown recommendation
that would get a majority of the traffic
now as a majority is like more than 90%
so it was hard for us to compare two
recommendations for the same product so
what we eventually ended up doing was
that we computed an average we computed
the probability that you would click on
any one of the recommendations but I
think this method can be easily extended
to the scenario that you are mentioning
you can compare our different ranks of
recommendations and you can also compare
different recommendation systems so
suppose you had a recommendation last
year and now you put a new one today and
you can just go back in the logs for
both of them and check what's the causal
estimate and if you have some way of
injecting randomization into you can
also go back and check each that using
what was the effect maybe I meant to say
arbitrary not random but yeah if you had
some recommendations which were
different for whatever reason then you
can see their effect and and then later
figure out why that recommendation was
better clicked and improve algorithms